Dr Peterson thank you for coming.
We appreciate it a lot.
Uh,
I wanted to get your opinion on
censorship that we're seeing on the web.
Uh,
it's accelerating.
You were a very notable example.
You were locked out of your g mail in
the interim account.
Pardon me?
Oh yeah.
Trump just got a deleted by an errand
person,
you know,
now they're saying that perhaps this was
just a contractor and,
you know,
maybe,
uh,
someone from twitter who's gone into
very far left direction a youtube has
gone very far left direction.
Uh,
I'm just wondering,
I've started an alternative to youtube
called Pew Tube.
What kind of,
um,
what,
what do you see for possible solutions
and just your thoughts in general.
Here's a crazy thought,
but I'm going to tell it to you anyways.
So I was just reading one of Ray
Kurzweil's books,
I think it was called how to make a
mind.
I really liked it actually.
It helped me understand how the brain
compresses information because the world
is really complicated,
so you have to make a low resolution
representations of it to live in it.
And he actually explained to me in a way
that I hadn't really understood how the
brain might do that neurologically.
So that was cool.
But you know,
Kurtzweil is this guy who thinks that
he's a smart guy,
very smart guy,
and he's invented a fair bit of high end
technical technological software and
hardware and he's the guy that thinks
that we're heading towards the
singularity.
And so the singularity is,
you know,
how processing speed doubles every 18
months and like hard disk capacity every
year and there's a bunch of doublings
going on,
a huge number of them and they
accelerate exponentially.
And so it's probably,
we're probably three years away,
maybe even less than from building a
computer that has the capacity to make
as many calculations as reasonable
estimates of the calculating capacity of
the human brain are currently set out.
Eighteen months away,
two years away,
something like that.
And then we're 18 months away from
having one that's twice that fast.
And then 18 months away from having one
that's twice as fast as that.
So that's like say six years and we've
got something that's eight times as
smart as a human being,
but there's a twist on that and this is
Kurt swells twist,
which is as soon as you make a machine
smart enough to make the next machine
that's smarter than it,
which is sort of what we're doing
because computers are so fast that that
will scale up to near infinite computing
power computing power almost
instantaneously now me think no,
probably not.
And Alan Gates partner has written
critiques of Kurtzweil and you know,
you might think if something's
impossible then it won't happen even if
you don't know why.
And there's reasons to,
to not think that that will happen.
But Kurzweil's traced to back the of
computing power way before the existence
of the transistor and it's been
ridiculously stable,
crazily stable.
So God only knows what we're coming up
with here.
You know,
and you don't know what something have
infinite computing power.
It might be like,
like you seriously don't know.
And there are serious people who are
very,
very worried about that.
They're very worried,
for example,
that companies like facebook and Google
will manage that first and you know,
those companies are already making
censorship,
ai bots and that's what that smart.
It's sorta like making really fast
robots that can shoot people.
It's not that smart and we're doing that
to very rapidly and you know,
I know some guys who work in advanced
Ai,
you know how you look,
you watch the term terminator movies and
you see the robots that miss when they
shoot at you,
like they're not very bright because the
bright ones not only shoot at where you
are,
but they estimate where you're going to
be when you make your escape moves and
they shoot their simultaneously and
their death rate is 100 percent.
And so there's no war against the
robots.
I mean,
when those things get going,
they're going to be so much faster than
us that will look like we're moving
through molasses to them.
So
you know,
so maybe what we're deciding now with
all of our individual decisions about
censorship and the way that we're going
to construct the world and all that is
exactly what kind of super intelligence
we're going to bring into being.
And I would suggest that we try to bring
one in that's good and moral rather than
one that's evil and demonic.
Right?
So what can we do about that?
The.
There's only one answer to that.
As far as I know that that works is gay
rock together.
You're going to be the person who's
working in Ai,
right?
I know some of these people,
they better be good people because
they're going to build whatever they're
like into their machines.
They better have their head screwed on
straight because they're going to get
amplified like mad.
And I don't like what's happening with
Google and facebook and youtube.
They're building censorship bots
predicated on a certain kind of
ideology.
The ideology that we outlined today.
It's a very bad idea.
Hopefully good people will stop that.
So then that.
What that means is that your moral
obligation is to be good and the way you
do that is first by stopping being bad
and everyone can do that a little bit.
So I hope that's what everyone does
because the consequences of not doing it
are not going to be pleasant.
They never are.
Thank you.
Hi,
this question is about your biblical
lecture series.
Um,
I like that one because it's about
genesis,
which is usually ignored as being where
this post enlightenment society.
We need these ancient creation myths.
And also I thought revelations kind of
gets the same treatment as being
dismissed because it's the crazy
hallucinogenic trip trip,
some isolated madman in the middle of
the Mediterranean.
So I was wondering if after you're done
with genesis,
if you were thinking about doing
revelation's,
not without traversing the Geo geography
in between.
Okay.
Yeah.
I want to walk through the whole thing
if I can do that before they expire.
So I mean I've read it and thought about
it and it like,
it's such a strange book,
a because it's really big among the
evangelical Republican types.
And you'd think really,
really,
that's the book that's.
But you're relying.
Have you read it?
It's,
it's,
it's a crazy hallucinogenic trip.
That's what revelation is.
Now.
That's not to play it down because God
only knows about crazy hallucinogenic
trips,
that's for sure.
I mean there's,
there's accruing evidence.
I would say that a tremendous amount of
the religious orientation of human
beings,
deep mythological,
symbolic orientation is in no small part
a consequence of humanities
experimentation with psychedelics
substances.
I think that's,
that the evidence for that I think has
become virtually an overwhelming.
So anyways,
I will get there.
Maybe.
Probably not because at the rate I'm
going through the first stories,
it'll take me forever to get there,
but that's okay.
So.
All right,
thank you.
Yep.